اذا مشاهدينا توتر حدودي لم نشهده منذ
سنوات عشرات الصواريخ اطلقت من الاراضي
اللبنانيه باتجاه اسرائيل نعود لكيف بدا
طبعا مراسل العربيه قال ان عدد الصواريخ
كانت اربعه وثلاثين اسقط الجيش الاسرائيلي
25 منها عبر منظومه القبه الحديديه فيما
سقطت تسعه صواريخ بمناطق عده تسببت باصابه
ثلاثه اسرائيليين ردا على ذلك قصفت
اسرائيل لاطراف بلدتي القليل والمعليه في
قضاء صور جنوبي لبنان بالمدفعيه الثقيله
وفق الوكاله الوطنيه للاعلام وهي المنطقه
التي اطلقت منها صواريخ الكاتيو كما لفتت
هيئه البث الاسرائيليه الى اغلاق المعابر
من حيفا حتى الحدود مع لبنان واغلاق
المجال الجوي شمالي اسرائيل وفي وقت نفت
فيه ميليشيات حزب الله علاقتها باطلاق هذه
الصواريخ اشارت التقييمات الامنيه
الاسرائيليه الى وقوف فصائل فلسطينيه خلف
الامر مشدده على ان اطلاق هكذا هجمات من
الاراضي اللبنانيه لن يتم الا بعلم من
ميليشيات حزب الله
[موسيقى]